un point maintenant sur l'économie et
plus particulièrement sur
l'entrepreneuriat c'est avec vous
Nicolas dandry bonsoir vous venez de
nous rejoindre et on va parler du ski
cube qui a soufflé
6 ans d'existence pour l'incubateur de
50 ans en Yvelines qui est situé donc à
Guyancourt et il a déjà accompagné 60
startups vous savez à travers des
programmes à la fois d'incubation mais
aussi d'accélération c'est destiné
notamment à des startups qui sont déjà
existantes et qui se développent et dans
le dernier numéro avec Patrick Jacques
de dixmu nous sommes allés au ski cube
le dernier numéro du Sky Eco le magazine
économique que vous pouvez retrouver sur
sur le site internet ou sur nos réseaux
sociaux mais on allait voir Jean-Luc
mélo le directeur du ski qui tire le
bilan et bien de l'activité du ski cube
une belle aventure c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on a ouvert ce site il y avait
quelque part une notion un peu
d'expérimentation puisque c'était
nouveau pour le territoire de
Saint-Quentin et on se rend compte que
après 5 6 années maintenant de
d'activité qu'il a toute son utilité et
qui qui s'est doté de riches
d'expérience au bénéfice des entreprises
du territoire alors le principe de
l'incubateur c'est d'accueillir des
startups pour les faire grandir les
lancer comment quel bilan vous faites en
termes de chiffres combien d'entreprises
vous avez accueillies alors des startups
vous avez raison puisque c'est quelque
part la vitrine du site avec notre
incubateur dont on parlera sans doute
mais beaucoup d'autres projets et de
d'action porter à destination des
entreprises en création d'entreprise
d'une manière générale mais également
avec les entreprises en activité
principalement autour des des ressources
humaines et l'accompagnement en termes
de RH voilà donc beaucoup beaucoup de
d'activités et l'incubateur pour
terminer sur sur ce sujet là
l'incubateur avec plus d'une soixantaine
de start-up qui ont été accueillies et
durant ces premières années d'activité
est-ce que il y a des histoires qui vous
ont marqué des succès story économiques
nés ici à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines oui
oui alors on a maintenant des
entreprises effectivement dont on est
particulièrement fiers vous allez
effectivement rencontrer quelques-unes
je pourrais en évoquer d'autres comme
l'Accord que effectivement que vous avez
déjà eu avec lequel vous avez déjà eu
l'occasion d'échanger dans d'autres
d'autres contextes voilà des entreprises
qui aujourd'hui
tracent leur chemin mobilisent des des
fonds arrivent à avoir une bonne
relation avec l'écosystème du territoire
et si je ne prends l'exemple que
l'accord c'est pour nous un exemple
qu'on cite souvent parce qu'il est eu un
cheminement au-delà de l'accompagnement
qu'on a pu lui proposer d'intégration
dans l'écosystème puisqu'à kermesse qui
est une très belle PME du territoire a
pris une participation dans dans cette
entreprise est aujourd'hui un acteur
capital sans jeu de mots dans la
dynamique en tout cas dans le
développement de cette start-up qu'on a
eu plaisir d'accompagner pendant
quelques années
[Musique]
alors Awa Fofana Vincent Miro de nouveau
deux dirigeants qui vont intégrer le ski
cube de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on
vient de l'entendre la Corse c'est un
exemple pour le ski cube donc c'est une
startup qui a été incubé bon c'est des
portiques un concept de sûreté pour
protéger les grands événements c'est pas
le même activité que vous mais est-ce
que ce sera un rêve peut-être de
collaborer avec une PME une ti un grand
groupe peut-être avec votre start-up à
terme bien évidemment enfin quand on est
quand on crée une société comme ça on
recherche évidemment le des partenariats
des des
on nous un réseau qui nous va me
permettre évidemment de développer notre
activité donc avec cette société là en
particulier je ne sais pas je ne la
connais pas peut-être pas parce que bon
des portiques de sécurité c'est pas
forcément très en lien mais c'est vrai
que ça fait toujours plaisir de voir des
sociétés comme ça qui réussissent et
c'est proche de nous puisque voilà ils
sont passés dans l'incubateur qu'on
aujourd'hui donc voilà
on est au bon endroit mais aussi
c'est ceux qui vont nous aider à
concrétiser notre projet donc tout à
fait alors pourquoi vous avez rejoint
alors peut-être rappeler votre projet
votre concept d'abord et puis pourquoi
avoir rejoint le ski cube du coup alors
moi mon projet c'est d'accompagner les
salariés donc d'être leur copilote
financier pour mieux comprendre leur
rémunération et les enjeux qui a
derrière un bulletin de salaire parce
que la plupart des salariés ne
comprennent pas leur bulletin et ce
n'était pas lié à des compétences ou un
manque de connaissances mais c'est
vraiment qu'on ne leur a jamais expliqué
et l'idée de check ta paye c'est
d'apprendre aux salariés à lire et
comprendre leur bulletins de salaire et
aussi de leur permettre d'avoir des
experts indépendants qui sont à leur
service pour leur permettre de
comprendre leur rémunération alors
quelles sont les attentes du ski cube du
coup par rapport au ski cube alors
effectivement moi je me suis lancé sur
les réseaux sociaux en avril 2021
aujourd'hui j'ai une communauté d'un peu
plus de 20000 abonnés tous réseaux
sociaux confondus donc des salariés qui
sont désireux de mieux comprendre leur
paye mais je n'ai pas la structure je
suis pour l'instant encore toute seule
donc il va falloir que je trouve mon
business model que je me lance que je
crée une équipe et j'ai besoin d'être
accompagné là-dessus et c'est sur ça que
j'attends le ski cube qui m'accompagne
pour aller à un autre niveau alors
comment vous avez venu cette idée de
créer check tapis ça vient 12 à part
d'un constat que les Français en général
ne savent pas bien lire leur fiche de
paie alors moi ça fait 12 ans que je
fais de la paye j'ai été gestionnaire de
paie ensuite j'ai évolué vers des
fonctions de chef de projet SIRH et donc
j'ai toujours travaillé étroitement en
contact avec des salariés mais également
avec des gestionnaires de paie et des
responsables de paye et on c'est un
constat qui est unanime on ne comprend
pas le bulletin de salaire et c'est pas
un secret et à côté de ça
personnellement dans ma vie personnelle
un peu comme les médecins quand ils sont
un dîner de famille et on leur demande
tout le temps est-ce que j'ai un bobo là
est-ce que tu peux m'expliquer ben moi
quand je disais que j'étais gestionnaire
de paie il y avait toujours quelqu'un
qui me disait ah mais il y a un truc
bizarre sur ma paye j'ai pas compris ça
te dirait pas de regarder et parfois on
sait quand même qu'il y a un tabou en
termes de rémunération et parfois même
s'ils étaient pas très proches ils
avaient tellement pas de solutions
qu'ils étaient prêts montrer leur fiche
de paye leur salaire pour que je puisse
les aider à mieux comprendre ce qui se
passait sur leur butin c'est vraiment un
exemple c'est l'exemple même de
l'entrepreneuriat et c'est pareil pour
Vincent Miro il y a un problème qui se
pose il y a une demande clairement c'est
comme ça et puis l'entrepreneur va
répondre à cette demande et développer
une offre c'est le cas aussi de Vincent
Miro vous le constat que vous avez fait
c'est dans le milieu hospitalier c'est
ça exactement donc dans le milieu
hospitalier
remonter des équipes opérationnelles
soignante médicale
qui qui ne trouvait pas qui ne trouvait
pas d'outils qui répondent à leurs
attentes des
attentes qui sont opérationnelles et
c'est vrai que les blocs opératoires
aujourd'hui ont tous un logiciel qui
permet de de piloter leur activité mais
c'est des logiciels qui ont souvent une
une vision un petit peu administrative
et
c'est ça pose des soucis aujourd'hui
dans l'articulation des équipes à un
moment où on a besoin de beaucoup
d'agilité et où on a besoin de partager
beaucoup d'informations pour faciliter
le travail des uns et des autres puisque
c'est c'est un endroit le bloc
opératoire qui qui fait l'air nombre
d'équipes qui travaillent en amont en
aval et au sein et au sein du bloc
opératoire voilà et donc notre objectif
c'est d'améliorer l'utilisation de ce
bloc opératoire pour utiliser au mieux
les ressources de l'hôpital mais c'est
aussi d'essayer de faciliter le travail
du personnel soignant et on sait qu'il y
a un enjeu sur le personnel soignant
personnel médical à l'hôpital c'est un
secret pour personne
dans le staffing de ces équipes là et
dans dans la qualité de vie au travail
de ces équipes à l'hôpital c'est une
dernière question parce que on bat des
records ces dernières années sur la
création d'entreprise en France l'année
dernière en 2022 il y a plus de millions
de création d'entreprises qui ont été
faites durant l'année pourquoi vous vous
êtes lancé dans l'entrepreneuriat
qu'est-ce qui vous a motivé c'est la
liberté souvent on entend cette petite
ce petit refrain de la liberté
d'entreprendre parce qu'on a plus de
liberté quand on est entrepreneur et pas
salarié
alors oui ça c'est la liberté bien
évidemment en tout cas c'est vrai que
ces derniers temps on a de plus en plus
de facilité à entreprendre et c'est tant
mieux on est accompagné d'ailleurs avec
le ski cube voilà on va être accompagné
aidé donc c'est vrai que c'est
l'entrepreneuriat c'est avant tout du
bon sens mais c'est aussi finalement
savoir
quand même prendre les bonnes directions
parce que voilà la liberté c'est 360 et
il faut faire les bons choix à des
moments où
le champ des possibles est total
et il faut choisir les bons acteurs avec
lequel faire faire les partenariats avec
lesquels monter monter les bons dossiers
pour pour avancer et vous
moi je suis convaincue qu'en tant que
salarié on est aussi libre qu'en tant
qu'entrepreneur alors du coup c'est pour
ça que j'ai voulu me lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat parce que sur le
marché j'avais pas cette réponse pour
aider les salariés et maintenant je
pense qu'avec check à paye les salariés
auront le pouvoir d'être aussi libre que
les entrepreneurs et de mener leur
carrière dans la direction qu'il
souhaite moi j'avais une dernière
question quand même Nicolas si vous
aviez devant vous une personne qui
hésite à se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat qu'est-ce que vous lui
diriez si elle a eu elle a son idée
depuis plusieurs années mais elle hésite
à se lancer à créer sa propre entreprise
qu'est-ce qu'elle conseille vous lui
donneriez
faut pas avoir peur en fait c'est avant
tout ça mais quand on a une idée et
qu'on a envie c'est l'envie qui fait qui
fait l'essentiel dans l'entrepreneuriat
voilà
donc on a envie il faut y aller ensuite
on est accompagné non ça veut dire quand
on a envie
c'est pas l'envie c'est pas n'est pas
n'est pas hors sol
on voit quelque chose on se sent pris
par une idée et il faut la développer
moi j'ai envie de dire que les sont des
gens comme tout le monde on n'est pas
spécialement plus visionnaire mais on
fait la politique des petits pas on met
un pas devant l'autre on regarde juste
le pas devant nous et si ça marche tant
mieux et si ça marche pas on Bifurk et
donc ça se passe très très bien juste
pour conclure Mathilde donc ce soir on
avait Awa Fofana donc les fondatrice de
check tapé et Vincent Miro le fondateur
de Médoc mais il y a trois autres
startups qui vont intégrer le ce qui
cube dans les prochains jours il y a du
new space avec astrolab il y a yeldi
c'est une fintech et manuscrit qui est
plutôt orienté vers le marketing voilà
bon on les découvrira au courant de
l'année on suivra vos aventures aussi à
tous les deux dans le Sky Eco voilà où
vous invite quand vous voulez
dans votre émission skyco Nicolas merci
à vous deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation